I'm John Aden with collaborative for
universal health thrilled to be here at
the Wolfram technology conference 2019
I'm going to just share a few case
examples of how Mathematica tools can
help out in the US healthcare system
filling gaps and information and
producing better information that makes
a difference in health care thank you
I'm John Aden and welcome you to a
little discussion of some experience
from looking at basic algorithms for US
healthcare I do that work on behalf of
collaborative for universal health a
small nonprofit that has background
helping solve information gaps for
hospitals doctors health plans and life
sciences companies as well as quite a
lot of attention to public health a very
interesting domain where we have a lot
of critical outputs very little funding
and precious few resources a little bit
of a perspective to guide the discussion
that I'll be sharing with you there's
obviously a national concern that we're
putting a lot of money into healthcare -
we're at a macroeconomic problem it's a
challenging issue there have been
significant investments in getting the
digital patient record into the system
something that has been going on for
years and many have participated with
good results and also the occasional
picture of physicians and white coats
lined up for access to a keyboard and
there's the certified vendors of these
digital systems and comments folks make
that these complex environments are kind
of like a walled garden where it can be
hard to get in and get out and we've
looked at how do you provide some
missing information in that setting and
especially can a small nonprofit they
actually do anything and our perspective
is that if you understand wolfram
research in Mathematica it's possible I
do want to guide this with just a few
observations that provide an orientation
to that somewhat eliminated our approach
and some of the choices we've made one
of them comes from private informal
course I once heard the professor
richard fineman giving that the
successful scientist must know when to
discard the extraneous results and some
of that mindset came into shaping some
of our choice
this year and other is a work that goes
back a while to Thomas Kuhn who did very
interesting things on how linguistics
colors perception which i think is
actually at play in both scenarios that
I'll share with you and that one is what
we see can be influenced by what we've
seen and understood before and another
one from a fellow who I was able to
contract as a coach for the first outing
of health information exchange who
commented that innovation is not the
problem it's clearing the mind of the
old ideas so that the new thought can
emerge and yet another one that I think
is important in healthcare where a lot
of it is all expensive and big money
which is the late professor CK Prahalad
a colleague of his pointed me to this
work and the idea that part of
envisioning a successful future that's
inclusive will be doing things in a way
that with profitable service embraces
the unfortunate the unserved and the
many billions around the world who need
these good solutions and good
information but don't necessarily have
the kind of resource we have to afford
it so the first one looks at clinical
practice guidelines we went to the
digital patient chart started years ago
came very quickly lots of money invested
after that process including the
definition of the certified electronic
health record came we had Affordable
Care a political compromise with
affordable care it became important to
use clinical practice guidelines
something in the field of medicine that
professors would develop and as part of
training the medical students on
differential diagnosis would help them
know when to look at a clinical practice
guideline which would be a template for
dealing with a particular condition and
the clinical practice guideline would
give them some rule ins when to use it
rule outs when not to use it some care
selections and some follow-up steps and
those would be typically printed there's
been projects in the recent time where
working under a contract
with clinical practice guidelines they
would be laminated and the physician
could refer to them and then their
encounter note which would be quite a
lot of typing would go into the digital
system as a type note easily five
hundred a thousand keystrokes and what
we did was just produced a simple
Wolfram language script deployed with
the CDF player to structure these and
that meant that even though the system
that they're running a very expensive
digital system does not no clinical
practice guidelines you could use the
CDF make the selection of how the
particular guideline is used for the
patient paste it in and proceed along
the way
the traditional approach would be to
spend into the millions of dollars to
modify the digital system and attempt to
put the pieces of each guideline within
the digital system which can work and
people would make that investment if
they had the money and they would then
say okay and using our digital system we
follow the guidelines but then there'd
be the tiny thing can you track the use
of the guidelines and when the
guidelines are decomposed and spread
throughout the digital system there's
often not the reporting to be able to
know that whereas a clever thing if you
use a CDF and the consumption of a
guideline that may have a few dozen
steps is just a yes/no which of the
steps in the guideline were selected
it's a tiny little bit of data that can
be safely stored in a database or
anywhere that then reports across to all
the encounters use of the guideline and
it's also interesting that if you have a
typical enterprise structure of a health
system with the hospital and their
digital system many medical offices in
their digital system which could be
dozens of different choices that each
office would make what digital system
would they like
with an encounter note each time the
physician works with the patient use of
a CDF script allows across the whole
environment a uniform way to just track
in a which guideline and what elements
are used or not used and why at each
encounter so the question does it
actually work
the folks who used it and loved it were
uncomfortable with me sharing any detail
ultimately the health system they were
in decided to invest the big millions of
dollars and script all the guidelines
into the systems and give access to this
common system to many many physicians at
no cost to the physician which is an
accounting problem for the health system
but just kind of beyond our scope today
but we did find that it worked and it
worked very successfully and we're
considering after this conference
offering the capability in a general way
and we believe that we'll be able to do
that at whatever cost that the hospital
would like in fact our initial thought
was to tell them they can pick you know
any price scheme they want pay our
nonprofit half for the service and if
they decide they want to give it away
that'll be ok but if they call and ask
questions we might charge them so that's
one where we've got some experience I
wish I could show you more about it but
that has issues happy to discuss further
but we did demonstrate that the cdf
worked to augment the digital patient
chart the next thing that came along
this spring was CMS the group over
Medicare and Medicaid said we'd like to
demonstrate some explainable AI that
helps and that was a very nice challenge
they put money behind it and I said
we'll even provide the limited data set
of healthcare claims that you can use to
provide a solution so we were wondering
where would we look for a solution
domain and with some of the chief
medical officers which our nonprofit
seems to collect we state our mission
and people show up let us help you we
thought about it and figured we would go
after opioid use
disorder we were coached that in the
case of opioid use disorder where
billions of dollars are going into a
medication assisted treatment as a
bonafide way to help people stuck with
opioid addiction to shift to a healthy
outcome that there's not a measure for
success or failure other than the
patient did not die and that many of the
public health studies that are looking
at what is the success of the treatment
programs are basically taking the single
input of the coroner's mortality report
to assess program success so we were
thinking maybe we could suggest a way to
use claims and come up with a predictive
measure of who might be at risk because
if we're going to spend billions of
dollars and we have the capacity to
surge on individuals who might be at
risk and we can get there soon enough
maybe we don't have to see them on the
coroner's mortality report so that was
our proposal that we could use a simple
machine learning template that's built
in with Mathematica they would give us
the data set and we would come up with
treatment failure risk now there's a lot
of you have to have been hands-on with
the reality of the claims and the data
and the medical ontology and everything
that's coated into that in order to
perhaps pre process it and run it in a
tool such as we now have with
Mathematica but we felt it was worth
raising her hand and saying we would
like to go for it we think it's possible
now the other thing we did is we said
because the standard in health analytics
is a settled claim where you give a
claim where the hospital or the
physician did something or the pharmacy
dispensed something and there was a
claim there's a practice of waiting
ninety days and working from the settled
claim
so that's where we were thinking well
maybe we could do a predictive model and
validate it still 90 days to settle the
claim and in the case of a dynamic
health condition that could be a Bugaboo
so I had had a personal interest in
these social determinants of health
which is all the information not in the
medical environment but available about
the person that might be used to
understand aspects of how they're doing
and so we also in our submission said if
you invite us to the program we'll try
to show that the 90-day latency claims
are useful we will also try to show that
we can find some of these social
determinants of health which can be
available with in a 72 hour latency and
you can even get it with 24 hours
latency if you know where to look and
the sources to hire will try to get a
low latency model I'll do questions I'll
do questions later that'll work best as
time is tight we'll need to turn the
room over in a short period of time so
we'd be put that in and what what
happened was the group doing the
evaluation and are you apply in February
they're announcing in June and it got to
be late May and they said oh my goodness
it's gonna take till October to figure
out who do permit to go forward with
their proposal and I would tell you that
we're about to see Halloween and finish
October and I've asked them do you think
you're gonna decide and maybe November
December next year or are we just going
to give up on the idea they did have a
Foundation grant a few million dollars
to invite people to do this work but
they're choking on it I don't know but I
do think that this kind of illustrates
the challenge and the complexity of
healthcare especially in the u.s. domain
where we are information rich in many
ways but sometimes you have to use some
of the observations to be kind of like a
information analytics Jujitsu person and
think very clearly and carefully about
what are the goals or other goals
possible what are the resources and
where might be the opportune
to use the kind of condensed horsepower
that knowledge of Mathematica brings to
potentially make a difference so and
with that we have time for Q&A please